one of the biggest storylines on TV
right now is who will permanently
replace Michael Strahan online could it
be Fred Savage you know adorable friend
from The Wonder Years well he is in the
middle of coaching three times this week
so we put Fred on the spot this morning
just moments after he left live bat
today is Fred 700 this is this is just I
coming in town with my family they're
meeting me here we're taking a vacation
in New York so the timing worked out and
whatever they call I love to come to it
it's always a lot of fun he's not giving
anything up but we're calling him Fred
the front runner I enjoy it so much I
love interacting with the audience I
love sitting beside Kelly to work with
someone who's just at the top of her
field is a is a thrill so I it's always
enjoyable to come to it I think he's the
cutest thing ever I think he's he's a
great big Fred yeah he's so fine he like
needs to be hired immediately it's gotta
be the Kelly and Fred show there sure
are a lot of clue that's why he could be
the one I was like welcome home babe I
feel very comfortable that first
frequency since Dre him let's live Fred
we'll have co-hosted five times and Bank
some future episodes they did one full
show and then they did half of another
so we pre-taped for an August show and
he dropped on the show that he met with
a live exec maybe making a deal I had
the pleasure of going to dinner with art
more last night there were so many guys
out there I really I really don't know
who to who to recommend me but she's
working it out pretty good
you know she's hanging on to it Kelly is
reportedly partial to Anderson Cooper
now Cooper's pal Andy Cohen is not
looking to get the job but will be
sitting in again and a couple of weeks
they need to have people back again and
again and again so that you can really
see because in truth she helps you so
much when you're sitting there next to
her going for fred is the major
nostalgia factor
a little biased cuz Fred Savage is my
childhood because a whole generation was
crushing on The Wonder Years it's about
a twelve and a half year old kid who
rolls up in the 1960s now he's 40 the
father of three and the audience the
doors handbook the people in the
audience are enjoying it and responding
to it that's why you do it it's it's
real it's what you see is what you get